I want to ask this bro you have Berry
bonds as a hitting coach yeah and I had
Ken Griffey Jr as a hitting coach and
I'm gonna tell you my experience and I
want to hear about yours yeah so Griff
was our hitting coach for Team USA
and obviously we know Griff is Ken
Griffey Jr yeah
and
I think sometimes like when it when he
would help us with hitting because he
has all the knowledge in the world right
I think sometimes I couldn't understand
it and if he was saying it correctly
yeah but I just because he was King
Griffey Jr and he could do it yeah I
think he may have thought that I could
do it right and I can't do you know what
I'm saying some of the things but he was
amazing and all the knowledge that I
learned about just purely like
taking pictures or how to take pitches
or or just how to navigate it bats yeah
like that is stuff that he taught me
that
I mean it's Irreplaceable you know and
so I want to hear about Barry Bonds
because a lot of it's not mechanical a
lot of it is is just mental thought best
yeah
I mean Barry was so so talented like
everything he did like we were talking
about earlier about just like simple
repeatable he was like he had one of the
most simple repeatable strings of all
time and that's why he was able to do
what he did and
like him talking about hitting and
watching him hit it looked so easy like
he was watching he would like
demonstrate like the drill or what he
was talking about in the cage and you'd
just be watching like man like this
looks so easy yeah and then you'd go in
there and try and do it and you just
smother it I can't do that you know he
talked about his Top Hand a lot and like
catching the ball like you just like if
I can catch it yeah that's his drill
right right if you can put a glove on
and if you can catch it and he's like if
I can go from here to here before you
throw a ball from 60 feet to the plate
like I got you he's like you can it
doesn't matter how hard you throw like
I'm still gonna get you
and I remember I remember asking him
what he thought about the shift I was
like Barry what do you think about the
shift because that's kind of when the
shift was just starting out again like
he used to get shifted all the time for
the most of us like we weren't really
getting shifted a whole lot back then I
was like what do you think about this
shift okay he was like man the only
thing the shift did was stop me from
hitting 400. oh okay because you can't
you can't catch it if it's in the water
I was like ah
yeah that's funny